With its small town setting
and fresh-faced young lead,
DC's "Stargirl" is probably the sweetest
superhero show ever made — which is why
her dark history of murdered family members,
older boyfriends and more might surprise you.
Since she was first introduced as the new "Star
Spangled Kid" in 1999's "Stars and S.T.R.I.P.E.
#0," Courtney Whitmore has been treated with
great affection by her comic book creators.
This is due to the fact that her writer
Geoff Johns based Courtney's personality,
appearance and name after his sister Courtney
Johns. In several interviews about Stargirl,
Johns spoke of the real-life Courtney's, quote,
"spirit and optimistic energy that I wanted
to put back in the world with Stargirl."
Tragically, Courtney Johns died in the TWA Flight
800 disaster of 1996. Her comic book counterpart
became a tribute to her real-world inspiration,
and Courtney Johns was even memorialized
in the pilot episode of "Stargirl" by
placing an edited image of her in a photo
alongside "Stargirl" actress Brec Bassinger.
In the "Stargirl" TV show, Pat Dugan, played by
Luke Wilson, is Courtney Whitmore's stepfather
and the former sidekick to the superhero Starman,
played by Joel McHale. Together, the two fought
crime in the early twenty-first century before
Starman was killed and Dugan semi-retired.
In the comics, Dugan served as the sidekick
"Stripesy" to the Star-Spangled Kid during
World War II. The pair eventually joined
The Seven Soldiers of Victory, who were
scattered throughout time after a battle
with Nebula-Man. Dugan wound up in Ancient
Egypt where he was enslaved and forced
to work on the pyramids until members
of the Justice League of America rescued
him and brought him back to the present.
Dugan eventually found love with Courtney's mother
Barbara and took on the mantle of the armored hero
S.T.R.I.P.E. when his adopted daughter decided to
become a new Star-Spangled Kid. While his new life
came with plenty of challenges, he's probably
glad he didn't have to die in Ancient Egypt.
While most people accept that Courtney Whitmore
is a smart and capable young woman eager to help
others embrace the best sides of themselves,
she didn't start out that way. In fact,
in her early appearances, she came across as
an entitled brat who gets into the superhero
life for the most selfish of reasons —
to screw with her step-father's life.
In the original "Stars and S.T.R.I.P.E."
series, Courtney discovers the original
Star-Spangled Kid's gear in her step-father's
belongings and uses it to create her own
version of the Star-Spangled Kid's costume
and promptly starts getting into trouble.
Courtney even attempts to use her knowledge
of Dugan's superhero past to get her mother
to leave him. Luckily, Dugan and
Courtney gradually form a closer
relationship and Courtney's experiences
as Stargirl help her mature. Eventually,
she admits that she became a superhero for
the wrong reasons, and that her stepfather
was born with a moral compass that she
had to learn how to develop for herself.
Superheroes need to know how to take
care of themselves on the battlefield.
This is particularly true of young superheroes
whose inexperience might get them killed.
However, Courtney Whitmore often displays
such a violent streak in her fights
that readers are left feeling
almost sorry for her enemies.
In "Stars and S.T.R.I.P.E." #1, Courtney
meets a school bully on the first day at
her new high school and decides to kick him
in the face when he starts mouthing off.
Another issue actually shows Courtney kicking
a bad guy in the crotch during a battle
and relishing the opportunity to
use such dirty fighting tactics.
To be fair, many of the foes Stargirl faces
off against are homicidal and Courtney probably
does need to use such extreme force in certain
fights. Still, her hair-trigger temper does drive
her to fight nastily in her early appearances,
making her seem like a super-powered delinquent.
"Hey! Somebody's messing with your car!"
Family relationships can be tough for
superheroes, and Stargirl is no exception.
In fact, Courtney Whitmore's birth father Sam
Kurtis just gets worse in each of his appearances.
In a scene from "Stars and S.T.R.I.P.E."
#14 that was adapted for the TV show,
Sam shows up at Courtney's house on her
birthday and cons her out of a valuable locket,
claiming he needs to help a non-existent
brother. While Courtney sees through the con,
she hands over the locket anyway,
crushed by her dad's selfish cruelty.
Later, Courtney discovers Sam has joined
the supervillain group the Royal Flush
Gang under the alias "Two of Clubs."
During the "Infinite Crisis" storyline,
she's informed that Sam is dead, and
decides she doesn't want to waste her
time hating a dead man who never reformed.
Instead, she accepts that Pat Dugan is the
real father figure in her life and
chooses to identify as his daughter.
Courtney Whitmore met her original
arch-nemesis Cindy Burman, aka Shiv,
in high school during the "Stars
and S.T.R.I.P.E." series. In fact,
Cindy was the captain of the cheerleading squad
and a variation of the popular "mean girl" trope.
Sounds like a fun way to explore high school
rivalries in a superhero setting, right?
Well ... not so much. Turns out, Cindy was
the daughter of the Dragon King, a crime boss
who tortured and experimented on her to make
her a living weapon. Despite Cindy's pleas,
the Dragon King regularly had cybernetic implants
installed in her — often without any anesthesia.
Choosing to focus all of her anger and pain
on Courtney, Cindy attacked her superhero
counterpart with a homicidal rage born from
a life of constant abuse. Her tragic story is
so intriguing that the "Stargirl" television
series made it a major plotline in Season 1.
As portrayed by Meg DeLacy, Cindy/Shiv
is frightening and truly abhorrent,
but you can't help feeling
sorry for her at the same time.
Superheroes and supervillains tend
to be connected by shared tragedy,
and these two are no different. In "Stars
and S.T.R.I.P.E." issues 12 and 13,
the Dragon King used mind-control to turn
the youth of Blue Valley against the adults.
The brainwashing even worked on Courtney until she
managed to shake off its effects — distracting the
Dragon King long enough for the superhero
Shining Knight to battle the villain.
During the fight, the Dragon King fell off
his flying dragon and died in an explosion.
Shiv — who was still obsessed with making
her father "proud" — blamed Courtney for
the Dragon King's death and swore to kill
Courtney and everyone she cared about.
Although Courtney's actions were only indirectly
responsible for the Dragon King's fall — Shiv's
interpretation of the events earned the future
Stargirl an arch enemy. Ironically, in the
"Stargirl" TV series, Cindy stabs her father
in the back in retaliation for locking her up.
Nevertheless, she continues to see Stargirl as
her enemy and continues looking to take her down.
The path of true love never runs smoothly
for superheroes — and that's definitely
true for Stargirl, who found herself falling
for Billy Batson, a sixteen-year-old boy who
worked alongside her with the Justice Society
of America. Nothing wrong with that, right?
“No. Way.”
Well ... not quite. As fans
of the movie "Shazam!" know,
Billy Batson is the teenage alter-ego of
the superhero Shazam, or Captain Marvel
as he was known at the time, who looks like
he's in his late twenties or early thirties.
This made it look like Captain Marvel was
flirting with an underage girl when they
were hanging out with the Justice Society of
America. Although the two only actually dated
when Billy was in his teenage form, the rest of
the JSA, who were unaware of Captain Marvel's
true identity, called him out on the seemingly
inappropriate nature of their relationship.
Stargirl's first major romance might have been
rough, but her second was downright tragic.
Following Billy Batson's departure, Courtney found
herself developing feelings for Albert Rothstein,
aka Atom Smasher. Al eventually reciprocated, but
he later fell under the influence of Black Adam,
who convinced him to invade the
oppressed country of Khandaq
and kill it's dictator president, putting
him in direct conflict with the JSA.
In the ensuing battle, Al sacrifices himself
to save the people of Khandaq from the Spectre,
but a distraught Black Adam is able to
revive him almost immediately. Back home,
Al is put on trial for his
actions and pleads guilty,
but Courtney, never one to give up, promises
she'll be there for him when he gets out.
Making matters more difficult, there's an actual
age difference between Courtney and Albert,
although that doesn't seem to matter in
a possible future where an adult Courtney
is married to Albert. Audiences can also look
forward to seeing Noah Centineo play Atom Smasher
in the 2022 "Black Adam" movie alongside Dwayne
"The Rock" Johnson as Black Adam ... although
considering their comic book history, this
might not be so great for Atom Smasher.
At the core of Stargirl's appeal is her amazing
family dynamic. Few sidekicks are older than
the main hero, but S.T.R.I.P.E.'s relationship
with Stargirl is made special by the fact that
Pat Dugan is Courtney's stepfather and became
a superhero to support and look out for her.
In fact, Courtney regularly sees her family as the
inspiration for her superhero activities ... which
is why it was so traumatizing for her to
see them all murdered before her eyes.
This happened in "JSA" #68 when the
Red Morgue went back in time and
slaughtered Courtney's entire family
as they were all having breakfast.
Luckily, Time Master Rip Hunter
arrived soon after to save Courtney.
Rip helped assemble a team of JSA members to
travel to different points in time to erase the
events leading up to the Dugan-Whitmore
family's murder and set things right.
Saving the universe and leading a double life
can be tough on a person's mental health,
but one adventure saw Stargirl
literally land in an insane asylum.
During the events of the "Black
Vengeance" JSA storyline,
Courtney traveled back in time to erase
the events leading to her family's murder.
Courtney's mission was to travel to the year 1951
and recruit Ted Knight, the original Starman,
but unfortunately he was committed to
an insane asylum at that point in time.
Before she could convince him that she wasn't a
drug-induced hallucination, the asylum orderlies
spotted her and drugged her. Courtney was strapped
into a straitjacket and tossed into a padded cell.
Luckily, by "JSA" #70, Courtney's
time-traveling sister Patricia managed
to free her. While her time as a mental
patient was brief, it likely remains a
dark spot in Courtney's memory of how
superheroes are viewed by some people.
Despite the fact that she wears a mask, a
lot of people know that Courtney Whitmore and
Stargirl are one and the same. Her family,
the entire Justice Society of America,
and even several of her villains
know Stargirl's true identity.
As it turns out, a lot of this is due to
Courtney's carelessness — she once exposed her
secret identity to her friend Mary on the night
of her first adventure as the Star-Spangled Kid.
Sometimes, the fact that practically
everyone knows Courtney is Stargirl
is used for comedic effect — like when the JSA
visits Courtney during a dentist's appointment.
Other times, however, writers remind readers that
the reason for the secret identity was so villains
wouldn't come after the hero's loved ones ...
something that tragically happens to Stargirl.
"I put all of us in so much danger,
because I believed in some fairy tale."
In "Justice League of America" issues 10
through 12, Courtney gets on the supervillain
Shadow Thief's radar. A few issues later,
Shadow Thief tracks down Courtney's family,
wounds her mom, and kills her little brother.
Although the experience helps motivate Courtney
to be a better superhero, the cost is
extremely high ... and extremely dark.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.